armored Core 6 had a press showing
recently and some people are mad
Prescott to see a fair bit of one of the
game's missions and then a short snippet
of that was shown to the public this has
left some excited and others upset if
you follow other creators who cover
armored corsets you might have seen
videos popping up about whether the game
has too many new elements that seem too
souls-like most of the hubbub is about
features like repair kits camera lock-on
and boss fights part of the armor core
Community thinks these elements are too
far a departure from the DNA of the
series creators are getting lambasted
for calling it a Soul's life Die Hard
fans are mad and betrayed it's all very
melodramatic and I'm here to add fuel to
that fire because I was right armored
Core 6 won't be a Souls like but it will
be a sakiro light I didn't play the demo
myself but multiple creators who did
play it say that it has an impact or
stagger system which is essentially
straight from sekiro a while ago I had
reviewed some interviews from armored
core's game director masuro yamamura who
is also the lead designer for sekira
there I concluded that this game will
share some similarities with Sakura and
now I'm glad to be confirmed in my
reading that armor core 6 will be a
secular leg in case you missed it I'm
being a bit facetious yes with the new
elements armored Core 6 may be more like
sakiro and the Soul series than previous
AC games were but it is likely not going
to be a purebred sakura-like or
souls-like or anything like that just
because there are some new elements
which build off of from software's past
decade of new experience making games
doesn't mean that this is going to be a
Sci-Fi Mech Elden ring besides 2023
already has one AAA title that's a
Sci-Fi reskin of a fantasy RPG we don't
need another there's already been
significant discussion about each of the
new mechanics and speculation about how
they work this has been done better by
people who actually played and saw more
of the game so I won't be delving too
much into a breakdown in this video
check out vati or the lore Hunter if you
want to see more of that but let's keep
in mind that these creators are not
making definitive statements about what
Armory core 6 is and that makes sense
since even they only saw a small slice
of the game it is generally pretty poor
practice to make large assumptions about
a game but for much gameplay or review
has come out about it yes we can be
skeptical or cautious consumers but that
is different than making sweeping
judgments about a game because we're
worried just how Souls like a few new
mechanics are I'm basically echoing what
others have already said but decrying
this as a Soul's like is premature even
with these new mechanics plenty of new
games incorporate similar kinds of
features and manage to not be super
soulzy part of it is just the
progression of game development in the
industry now if you want to go around
calling armored Core 6 a secure like
then be my guest since that would be
pretty funny and I assume it would rile
people up even more but actual judgments
about the game should be held until the
mechanics are shown more in depth that
might be in another gameplay reveal or
it might have to wait until press
reviews of the game go out and get
talked about since we're basically two
months out from release it's not wild to
assume that process will start fairly
soon Chrome software had massive success
with Elden ring so economically they
should be in a pretty safe area armored
Core 6 has been in development for a
while so it's not 100 influenced by that
success but it's still granted a cushion
to be a bit more of a niche title kind
of like from software's version of one
for them one for me Army Corps doesn't
have to check all the boxes that Eldon
ring did it doesn't have to be the same
massive mainstream success but at the
same time it's not surprising that it
would take some mechanical influence
from the dev work fromsoft has been
doing for over a decade since the last
entry in the armored Core Series after
all the old armored cores can be a bit
unwieldy when it comes to controls so
some mechanical updates were bound to
happen and at the same time they don't
mean that what was core to the old games
has been completely abandoned let's
remember I am one for one when it comes
to armored Core predictions so I'm gonna
make another one Army Core 6 obviously
has some influences from sekiro Elden
ring and souls but it would be pretty
wild for it to not have its own identity
otherwise why would brumsoft even make
it and not just Elden ring 2. so we can
place a safe bet that Armory core 6 will
have plenty of armored Core spirit and
DNA making it a different experience
than what from soft Souls fans are used
to obviously nothing is certain until
the game comes out it could be a bait or
even just a bad game we've seen the
mighty of the game industry fall before
and it could happen to from software too
even if I don't think it's likely with
this game and what we've seen so far but
the informed prediction coming from the
self-proclaimed goat of arm and core
guesses is that it will be a genuine
armor core game with a good chunk of
mechanic updates that will likely make
it appeal to a wider audience the horror
at that thought this wider audience will
probably have more overlap with Souls
fans but I would bet the general gaming
audience will find it easier to get into
too all that's left to see is where on
the line of janky armored Core DNA
versus streamlined appeal it falls so
that's all I had to say for this video
no surprise I was right thanks for
watching thanks to my patrons for their
support and I can't wait to play Mecca
Sakura like 2023